good evening and welcome to that gyrus
today we'll be looking at a Casper
cartoon that's so joyous and cheerful
it'll make you want to slit your wrists
sit back and enjoy everyone else
we fucked up Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull all by ourselves
I don't want to read my cartoon what the
hell's wrong with you
famous studios now a subsidiary of
obscure pictures verse as sparber
is the nearest mother nature getting
kind of worthy featuring this soil
chewed up rubber condom and the only
taboos I'm gonna see is at the bottom of
Jack Daniel's bottle board wise Jan oh
god damn it Earl isn't this a perfect
setting for spine-tingling ghost story
well strangely enough this is a ghost
story
no mr. walls this is a fish stick
commercial do you have nightmares do
shadows on the wall for you
me neither well relax this isn't that
kind of a story this is a portal prove
it let me introduce a ghost that is out
of this world his name is Casper in life
he was known as the Pillsbury Doughboy
oh I wish I had animal friends to fondle
me well time for another kegger on Bald
Mountain this is Henry
he touched children but save the Pope so
he's in purgatory for a while where all
these guys pillowcases before they died
every night with the rise of the Moon
Casper's neighbors go off on their job
of scaring the daylights out of people
his neighbors were Klansmen you see
I'm off my beds
it's the ghost of Christopher Walken
buh-buh-buh
Kasper doesn't want to go out and boo
people he wants to be friendly they're
much less suspecting when he
chloroform's them and keeps them for
years in his pit Tesla sees no future in
the sort of life so he decides to go out
and make friends out of the piles of
dung that he found at his local farm but
Casper was hungry first what
mom I was attacked by the Michelin Man
splooge damn Jehovah's Witnesses I told
them to stay out
got nothing on that one folks
well time to die somewhere near a
highway and ruin everybody's trip Casper
was um unique huh can we be friends huh
ah the ghost of curly Joe taste the
remains of my chimichanga
Kasper tries to wash off the evil of
killing that homeless man on the Vegas
trip do we forget to show you that scene
well it happened we chose to keep it
from you because remember it's not that
kind of story
Oh buck up you know what they say what
doesn't kill you only makes you
chuckles puts down his sonic suffocating
pillow to see what was the matter and so
the dead boy cry because nobody living
or dead loved him and that in turn made
the cute little Fox wanna drown in his
own tears but don't get too sad kids
remember it's not that kind of story I
want you to me yeah you know what I'm
gonna get others to help you your face
off here this is what's left of your
body I think it was a femur Oh
do you want to play with me actually I
was hoping if I give you the stick you
go away
look as long as christina ricci in an
unfunny Eric Idle on InDesign
you know I'm just gonna start to ponder
the various ways that Casper could have
died heroin overdose auto-erotic
asphyxiation execution at the hands of
North Korean communists a tumor you know
what I'm just gonna start a website
about all the various ways he could have
died
you're my best friend so I'll give you
an extra special name Barty Fox would
wish that name on my worst enemy I'll
leave a flatulent trail for you uh eight
nine ten eleven twelve thank you
oh you'll never find me the only Bush in
the field as an army of Valkyries
bringing up the rear what
whoo ha whoo hoorah party
I smell a gassy Fox
Vica p and to the Republic for which it
stands
choo-choo-choo-choo choo-choo-choo-choo
Dhar you fucking fucks Oh buddy I can
smell this panic all the way from here
then the Fox almost fell off the
waterfall nearly drowning to death and
crushing his bones into a million pieces
but don't worry kids it's not that kind
of story
I thought they said this was a
children's cartoon
akhtar schnell schnell get in the fuckin
here I come together day
come on Fox do a barrel roll
oh my invisible pancreas my friend
I thought this wasn't that kind of story
lady lady my name is Ralph goddamnit you
Oh party are you alright Oh
lady what have I done
I killed the 30 my shit this is like
three Bambi's mom's and two old yellers
put together and so the dead boy buried
the dead Fox it was mowed down by the
hunters buckshot but don't worry kids
it's not that kind of story oh you
killed me Casper oh you're not seriously
Tommy this is the happy ending oh hello
and birdie lived happily ever join us
next time for Casper meet and Frank
don't worry kids it's not that kind of
story good night